all right let's go next so many people
holding it's hard to know where to go
let's try the 506 area code who's
calling today from five zero six hello
is this me yes it is who's this oh nice
my name is Julian from Costa Rica I had
a question related to your conversation
with sam harris that you've had recently
sir
i was wondering if you were convinced by
what sam claims is a distinction between
jihadists and white supremacists acting
based on their beliefs
for instance him claiming that white
supremacists emerge from a more
illuminating psychopathic or
pathological conditions instead of being
warranted by you know just a average day
joes falling to an attachment to these
kinds of ideological beliefs and sam
claiming that one important factor that
makes this discrepancy a non
hypocritical is the otherworldly you'll
get everything you want after you die
factor and him claiming that there is
some unknown chasm in the trolling ship
posting propagandistic narrative that
white supremacists try to get the media
spinning or something like that but it
seems that the same argument could be
made for the kind of propaganda that
jihadists engage in yeah i was not
convinced i I think I got it I was not
convinced by his argument I see listen
when I hear a jihadist explain what
motivates them and I hear a white
supremacist explain what motivates them
I presume the same amount of a genuine
statement from both of them barring some
particular reason to think otherwise and
no reason to think otherwise has been
presented now that doesn't mean that you
can't have in a plurality of cases
different circumstances that push
someone over the edge to the point at
which they commit real-world violence
but no I did not find
what sam harris said it didn't change my
mind so to speak right because it seemed
to me that him saying you know listen
it's not very known why these white
supremacists do what they do and then
they're connected to sites like 4chan
and it's just all a troll in his mind in
some cases but I've never seen him make
that claim for jihadist I've ever seen
him claim that jihadists are potentially
trolling and they're just trying to get
you know us media create me because they
hate Western powers so much or yeah I
mean I I called that as I saw I said to
him that I don't see that you know I
think the other thing is that that's
being ignored imagine that it was proven
that when a white supremacist when sorry
let me back up imagine that it was
proven that when we hear a claim that
someone who committed a mass violence
action was a white supremacist and we
figured out you know what they weren't
really motivated by meant by white
supremacy it was just convenient it
would or a troll it would still be
important to answer my question why are
so many people who aren't really white
supremacists going out there and
committing violence and then claiming
that white supremacy was the explanation
like that would still be an incredibly
relevant and important thing to answer
in society right I agree and I would
really appreciate it if you had another
conversation with Sam and try to clear
the air on this topic I don't know it
was it was made clear during our
conversation that we didn't agree I
don't know how soon he's gonna want to
do another interview with me but that
that's I'm glad to have him back on in
the future all right thank you very much
David you have a very capacious mind
love the show and I was surprised to
hear your Argentinian accent I didn't
discern it at all from you speaking
English it's pretty cool man I have a
bunch of Argentinian friends down here
so I should come visit one day yeah I
would love to go to Costa Rica I heard
that the place to go is you'll you'll
know the geography better than I would
there is a peninsula on the pacific side
what's the name of that peninsula I'm
not sure I can I can list some that that
could potentially be
be it have you heard um maybe of
Tamarindo bonacasa
exactly it's the area that has Tamarindo
and also I think puntarenas might be it
and yeah that entire area I have friends
who go there regularly the thing is
they've got to take two flights to get
there like from Boston you've got to go
somewhere and then to the capital and
then you've got to get an additional
ride all plane so it's like all day you
know right I would just caution you when
you come just beyond the whole
absolutely you don't really have this
problem because you speak Spanish but
foreigners are oftentimes overcharged
for the same services which is not
really unusual and in foreign countries
but right or in any country for that
matter right well certainly I will be
alright thank you very much everybody
okay thank you for the call appreciate
it great to hear from your first call
we've gotten from Costa Rica I love it